bonsoir laurent vraiment merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
dans une tribune poignante 1 publié le
10 février dans marianne vous dites on
m'a volé la mort de mon père vous
dénoncez ce que malheureusement beaucoup
de familles vivent pendant cette crise
sanitaire que s'est il passé
eh bien mon père a été hospitalisé pour
être soigné le vide et d'anglais on nous
a interdit de visite et au bout d'une
semaine il s'est réveillé il n'était
plus contaminés début jusqu'à trois
tests négatifs et pour autant nous
encore interdits de visite nous a
bloqués à l'entrée de service attendue
m'entends je suis absenté parce que on
lui disait qu'il allait mieux mais en
réalité il avait attrapé une infection
nosocomiale dans ce service qui fait qu'
il est décédé malheureusement et
finalement les médecins ils nous ont
rappelé que deux fois la première fois
pour nous dire de ne pas trop la plaie
vaut ne pas le déranger
la seconde annonce éléments de mon père
alors plus peut-être que le problème
d'une relation avec un médecin et c'est
en ce sens que votre témoignage et est
intéressant c'est tout un protocole que
vous dénoncez un protocole finalement
appliqué avec aveuglement sans humanité
c'est bien ça voilà en fait on se
réfugie derrière un protocole qui est
tout simplement inhumain et qui n'a
insisté
aucun fondement juridique donc des des
gestionnaires d'établissements et des
médecins profitent de la situation au
finalement exercer une sorte de contrôle
sur leurs patients et sur leurs familles
est ce que je dénonce en particulier
c'est l'accès aux eaux corps à la
dépouille d de nos malades aujourd'hui
qui est rendu au post qui a rendu
impossible par de nombreux chefs
d'établissement qui finalement
privilégie la mise en bière immédiate
qui fait que de nombreuses familles sont
aujourd'hui privés de des derniers ont
tranquillement autour de leurs des gens
donc ça veut dire concrètement laurent
vraiment que vous n'avez pu voir nous
votre papa
pendant sa maladie donc ils démarrent en
quelque sorte où seuls loin de ses
proches et que vous n'avez pas de le
voir non plus après avant qu'on
l'enterrent voilà donc les mains dans
une solitude la plus absolue la plus
totale sans pouvoir nous voir une
dernière fois sans pouvoir parler et
évidemment nous n'avons pas pu le revoir
avant s'est mise en bière
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous vous
ressentez de la tristesse de la colère
en mélange un mélange peut-être des deux
sentiments évidemment une très grande
tristesse est un traumatisme
considérable de de perdre son père dans
des conditions aussi affreuse pas
pouvoir lui dire au revoir de ne pas
pouvoir faire ses adieux à son visage
mais aussi un peu de colère vis-à-vis
d'un système qui a laissé ce genre de
situation prospérer dans l'impunité la
plus totale
donc j'essaie de transcender cette
colère elle a transformé aujourd'hui en
actions positives pour que ce genre de
situation ne puisse plus se produire
parce qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui des
milliers de familles qui sont bloqués à
l'entrée des services qui réclament
désespérément de voir leurs proches
je pense notamment aux ehpad aussi aux
hôpitaux et aux cliniques
donc il faut que cette situation cesse
d'urgence je vous coupe parce que je
vais vous laisser poursuivre et c'est
important de le signaler et vous c'était
dans une clinique privée vous vous dites
que ça revient au même à l'ap-hp aux
hôpitaux publics dans les ehpad cessé de
même combat c'est ce sont les mêmes
protocoles mêmes règles qui s'appliquent
exactement là on bosse à des milliers de
témoignages des personnes qui ont vécu
ce genre de situation tragique et c'est
de manière indifférenciée dans le public
et dans le privé
même si dans ces établissements il ya
souvent des équipes admirable qui font
tout pour permettre l'accès aux patients
et à fortiori aux mourants mais
malheureusement ce genre de situation
est observée dans tous types
d'établissements et donc c'est une
situation indigne qui fait reculer notre
humanité notre civilisation est donc
j'aimerais y mettre fin le plus
rapidement possible
laurent frémont clairement à quoi vous
attribuer cela parce qu'on parle souvent
ici même du manque de moyens des
hôpitaux d'aidé soignant il y as
peut-être de ceux là aussi on applique
des règles qui peuvent paraître
extrêmement inhumaine et elles le sont
quand on vous écoute bien évidemment
mais peut-être aussi faute de moyens
parce qu'on ne peut pas aussi gérer les
les proches de ces patients si ce serait
trop facile de désigner un coupable
je pense que nous sommes finalement tous
un peu coupable de cette situation parce
que nous avons laissé le monde de la
santé
dérivé peu à peu depuis des années vers
un système de plus en plus inhumain qui
est fondée aujourd'hui uniquement sur la
rentabilité sur des considérations de
gestionnaire et non plus sur des
considérations liées à l'humain à ce
qu'y fait la personne c'est-à-dire le
lien avec les autres
le contact tout ce qui entoure en fait
notre existence et donc certes on peut
déplorer un manque de moyens il me
semble que dans une société qui se dit
progressiste avancées pourraient au
moins deux blocs et débloqué des fonds
pour pouvoir équiper les familles et
nouméa au moins un référent par
établissement qui puisse donner des
nouvelles aux proches ça me semble
vraiment basique on a un pays qui se
prétend prétend avance avancée mais qui
finalement laisse mourir des gens dans
la solitude la plus totale et ça c'est
inadmissible mais jeu mais je le répète
certes il ya des gestionnaires qui ont
abusé de leur petit pouvoir mais nous
sommes finalement tous responsables de
cette situation parce que finalement la
crise ducobu n'est que le révélateur de
dysfonctionnements scandaleux qui ont
lieu depuis des années aux petits soins
de santé aujourd'hui clairement vous en
appelez à l'état et bien aujourd'hui les
gestionnaires qui bloque les visites
profite d'une sorte de vide juridique
c'est à dire que le relais cela
la permission d'interdire lé v de la
visite et donc il y en a qui en abusent
donc ce que je propose c'est d'instaurer
un droit opposable aux visites pour pour
que les familles qui se voient refuser
arbitrairement l'accès à leurs proches
puissent saisir le juge des référés en
urgence pour contraindre ces
établissements à ouvrir leurs portes
c est ce serait une manière aussi pour
gouvernement de rattraper des mois
d'inhumanité parce que cette situation
dure depuis mars
c'est autant de violations à notre
humanité et bien se répondent le
gouverneur au gouvernement un moyen de
se rattraper et finalement de compenser
ces mois d'inaction parce que dans le
discours officiel
on voit bien que le prison la république
comme les milices de la santé déclare
que les visites doivent être autorisées
mais dans les faits il laisse
aujourd'hui des gestionnaires se
comportait de manière arbitraire et je
dirais même dictatorial merci beaucoup
en tout cas ce moment vraiment pour
votre témoignage et bon courage à vous
merci merci